Another problem is that we
often use different words
to mean almost the same thing.
You can say cat or you can say kitty.
They're not the same, but
they mean similar things.
Remember that when we have things
that are similar, we really,
really would like to share
parameters between them.
But kitty is completely
different from cat.
So if we want to share
anything between them.
We're going to have to learn
that they are related.
So that's a very big problem for
deep learning.
We'd like to see those
important words often enough
to be able to learn
the meanings automatically.
And we'd also like to learn how
words relate to each other so
that we can share
parameters between them.
But that would mean collecting
a lot of label data.
In fact, it would require
way too much label data for
any task that really matters.